before we get out for our further win
you guys you guys at home we've been
tweeting my love life in five words
jokes all nights but I want to get a
hashtag soulmates over here a chance to
each throw in one of their own so ladies
first
Emily all right I have to say mmm
pulled out my Spanx cowboy all right
[Applause]
Brian you got to top that I might be
able to Emily will you marry me
[Applause]
all right
yeah
everyone screaming you said yes okay
really unfortunate doing all right
okay face do you have any idea time oh
my god
Brian your head yeah how are you feeling
I'm feeling pretty good right you're
good don't explain me your pants fully
filling with poop like everybody going
out how to do this like what a Gracie
got you got engaged on the show you guys
initially bonded over now you're gonna
go get married
I want you to Hawaiian name your first
kids together at midnight Hardwick in
the third think is a great name for a
kid so